bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e siamo su uno
dei titoli che mi avete richiesto di più
in tutto il 2020 che ai ragazzi little
nightmares 2 allo ragazzi gioco completo
uscirà a febbraio 21 me lo state già
chiedendo da febbraio 2020
quindi lo porterò di sicuro nel
frattempo ad allietare la nostra atleta
è uscita la demo ragazzi sono veramente
emozionato sono sincero perché non ho
idea di cosa aspettarmi il primo era
veramente figo
c'è un corridoio storto sono ubriaco
tanto ragazzi non mi ricordo veramente
nulla del primo little nightmare xvi
ricordo poca roba lasciare la cucina
occasioni proprio mi ricordo bene
vabbè sono un sacchetto sacchetto poi
quante vice di inside mi sta dando
ragazzi vi ricordate di said tipo uno
dei migliori gameplay del mio canali
assoluto non so se lo ricordate bene me
lo ricordo io guidavo un sacco di vice
alla insight la partenza così e che
comunque sono giochi dello stesso genere
quindi al regista c'è un televisore
interrompiamo il programma per
presentarvi leone cane fifone la donna
che figata giorno posso tirare fuori
barona horus ma dai che figata
bellissima sua tradizione e mo più
avanti di quanto ne yo yo no io penso
smi medesimo saprei personaggio e mi
ricordo ogni volta quanto io non
riuscirei a fare una roba genere perché
sai quanti ragni escono da seduti tutto
ok ti dice non sembra la forma finale di
inside quando cioè i mille braccia
bolero veneto è uguale potrebbe essere
un riferimento anche notato una scarpa
comunque avevo trovato una scarpa
lanciata sullo schermo però me la porto
possono andare su con la scarpa posso
andare le slot e mi portò magari non
serve a niente st scarpa mi sto facendo
di viaggio nia caso però ok del suo cane
del tronco yes
se noi non serve a niente perché a
questo punto avrei potuto anche lasciare
indietro sarebbe avrebbe funzionato
uguale è ormai può dio cioè qualcosa lì
c'è una trappola c'è una trappola
la vedo allora facciamo così io in
gabbia solo la scarpa a giocare effetto
veri che serviva la scarpa la pena per
la porta ancora dietro la scarpa mi ha
depistato la trappola attenzione ragazzi
bellissimo e libera protagonista non
sono io la scarpa ragazzi c'è la scarpa
è tutto questo è uno spot della nike è
in realtà non è un
adesso vi che lascia il gioco perché gli
sviluppatori non si aspettavano che una
scarpa arrivasse pilastro punto devo
fare qua io non la posso portare no no
la mia addio addio per sf tu per specchi
le scarpe ticino non raccogliete le
scarpe stiamo andando alle ondate
fermati madonna che casino quant'altro
che tempismo per cadere c'è il suo
tramonto incredibile poco mentre passo
io per adesso tutto fattibile era tutto
fattibile
cosa non scontata in un gioco molto
difficile come questo da capire cosa
bisogna fare
però la mia scarpa mi ha dato aiuto
finora ora cavarmela da solo ma io ci
credo credo nel cuore delle scarpe e
ragazzi crede di meno in voi stessi
perché non serve comunque che in chat
apa evadeva non essere così triste sono
affatto il tentativo è zio cosa devo far
cola o arriva il primo punto fermo del
gioco dove bisogna ragionare cosa che a
me risulta sempre molto complicato lo
sapete che non lo so parte il fatto che
comunque devo alzare questo ponte c'è un
accordo da quando tira la corda
ho capito ho capito tutto se prendo un
accordo fatto
se riesco a prendere la corda ho fatto
ve lo assicuro per scendere a ok potevo
scendere così io volevo scendere con la
corda prove
no io volevo fare addirittura un altra
cosa volevo attaccare la corda quel
marchingegno di prima per tirare per
questo tutto il ponte è vero che noi non
si arrampichi a questa scheda lancia la
stilo che perfetto niente scherzavo
io con la corda del ponte caduto volevo
legarla a qualcosa di prima per tirarlo
su con la manovella però anche così va
bene anzi meglio meno male che il 6
atletico zero cioè io sarei rimasto lì
tutta la vita morto video che bellissimo
che ma questo è il paradiso elevati che
queste sono le mie scarpe via ciò porco
del demonio io opterei per una blu
adesso non ragazzino mai più mai così
felice sono stato mai scarpa del mio
cuore a ragazzi le scarpe sono la svolta
insorge 400 le trovate le scarpe scarpe
caro amore vissuto pullulano aspettiamo
perché quella casa a grandezza naturale
ma ciò è vero che ero piccolo solo io
nel gioco di the nightmare giorno io
entro la finestra che dalla porta non ci
passo sono una cucina da incubo non fare
casino alzino fare casino anzi mette a
bollire il vino che potrebbe essere
interessante per la perfetta
the year amica gestioni ecco lì sono
stato io è nel caso nessuno avesse
sentito perfetto sta passando qualcuno
in cucina se non è stata accorgendo mi
serve capo che anche nell'atto di telaio
verso la cucina che facevano schifo
vedo che non è cambiata la faccenda è
guasta pasta possa lanciare la roba la
porta ma c'è un disco casinò e la metà
basta ragazzi prendono la lattina me la
porto è la ragazzi è tutto troppo
tranquillo non mi piace per niente
c'è un cappello
sei equipaggi i capelli raccolti dal
menopausa
ma dai ecco che mi siede in faccia ma
dai
sono un figo esito che suoni c'è una
finestra giù così forse posso entrare
dalla finestra perché come fa centro
ecco a portico demonio cioè la tizia 36
dei ragazzi devo dare il nome da dro
aiutare siete ha provato sfondo alla
porta
male non gliene frega niente non mi
sente neanche va bene e vedo che c'è una
specie un'altra porta a farmi vedere
processo a sfondare l'altro le lascia
perfetto non so con che criterio possa
sfondare la porta visto che lascia
enorme e io so cioè lascia di dimensioni
normali ma io sono un minio quindi non
so come aprire la porta su andy sono qui
wedding e shining del reboot tesoro non
ti volevo fare niente o un'ascia per
sbaglio o aspetta il supporto un
gomitolo in segno di amicizia sono un
amico io non ho sostenuto da parte lo so
può aprirla ma stai tranquilla non ti
vuole fare niente sono innocuo ciao sono
in opus un innocuo ma da una porta
dopo l di termoli
roma green jeans della camicia
infatti sto 5 che prestiamo la lo sapevo
lo sapevo che avrebbe corso usi brutta
stroncano andare via
volevo darti una mano certo liberata e
tu che vai così ma perché te ne vai è
stato fatto di qua si è aperta
supportano nell'aperta prima occhio
[Musica]
c'è qualcosa che mi turba però questi
sono immobili
quindi non è gente vivano perché non al
collo con il tizio in tutto sto casino
c'è qualcuno che muove pentole lo sento
tesoro la smettiamo e per favore fai e
quindi
sì sì avis pg tu ok allora di che sei
mia amica pensavo mi volesse contro di
me ci sono brava brava è cascata una
scarpa siamo a posto tesoro la scarpa e
ci porterà alla vittoria e la chiave è
qua quindi posso metterla qua dentro
teoricamente ok l'udc siamo bravissimi
ci sono impronte occhio è vieni vieni
vieni a i miei mezzi
occhio poi c'è qualcuno che ci segue
sicuro mi ci gioco quale vuoi
siamo in due dobbiamo approcciarci
secondo me perché se non ci sente che
sta facendo a trattare temi t.abel ai or
sono non ci vedono ci vedono ci vede
bene la porta a porta a porta a portà lo
aspettano la porta questa questo questo
abbiamo
non è espresso per aprire la porta con
ricordi capirà forse con rigore
oddio fucile oddio quella madonna che in
cattiveria ma che abbiamo fatto
capt danza sono morti sono mia i crediti
che ci sei poveri maledizione star
attento schivarlo dietro le casse
di sicuro di vita la casa di tua casa ok
e tanta cassa aiuto porco demonio
passaggio tra casse con rivas che
conoscitore per i care forse non ci ha
visti già visti in casa dove potremo mai
essere c'è un corpo zio madonna che
ansia siamo fermi sei fermo sei fermo
fermo prefetto perfetto stiamo avanzando
con lui la gag e ansia quando viene con
la torcia dobbiamo stare immobili fermi
immobili sono ci vede
no ragazzi un'ansia terribile che gioco
incredibile tra l'altro vuoi guardare
anche dall'altra parte no ok nel buco
nel muro cavi stile dogo
no no ma no
ce l'ho fatta ma cosa no questa era la
lite leitner sera la demo ovviamente
perché poi uscirà un gioco ufficiale che
io giocherò a febbraio speriamo che
valga la pena ma a quanto pare la demo è
bellissimo meraviglioso ai ragazzi che
vi sia piaciuto nel frattempo come se
quel momento è un bel mi piace la sotto
momento questo tu cosa ne pensate di
inter nightmare sempre fischiate e noi
come sempre ci vediamo a un prossimo
video belle ragazze
[Musica]